le dispararon en la ciudad occidental de
nara mientras hacía campaña solo dos
días antes de las elecciones a la cámara
alta de japón shinzo abe fue alcanzado
por dos disparos en la parte delantera
del cuello y fue trasladado en
helicóptero a un hospital donde murió
horas después el actual primer ministro
de japón dijo que estaba profundamente
entristecido por el asesinato como
anunció el hospital universitario de
nara el ex primer ministro shinzo abe
falleció a las 50 3 de esta tarde la
policía detuvo al pistolero tetsuya
llama grammy de 41 años ex integrante de
la marina del país utilizó lo que
parecía un arma artesanal y habría dicho
que apuntó a ave con la intención de
matarlo